ne sous-estimez pas le courage qui vous
a été nécessaire pour dénoncer au grand
jour les actions de votre ancien
employeur qui allait contre vos
convictions les plus profondes
je tenais donc en préalable à saluer
votre démarche vous dire que nous sommes
très heureux de vous accueillir ici au
sein de nos deux commissions il était là
c'est clair que seules les actions comme
la vôtre sont susceptibles de faire
bouger les lignes tant la domination des
grandes compagnies de l'internet propose
aujourd'hui sur un enchevêtrement de
technologie difficilement compréhensible
par le grand public et de lobbying
exercé avec des moyens démesurés
la commission de la culture s'intéresse
de longue date au sujet de la régulation
des réseaux sociaux je pense en
particulier aux travaux de catherine
morin desailly qui est à ma droite
travaux qui vous ont conduites chers
collègues à vous rendre à londres le 27
novembre 2018 pour participer avec des
parlementaires d'une dizaine de pays à
une science du digital culture médias et
sport committee de la chambre des
communes britannique
je note d'ailleurs que mark zuckerberg
avait fait preuve de moins de courage
que vous madame à logan en ne répondant
pas à l'invitation qui lui avait été
faite de venir alors s'exprimer sur
l'oeuvre la sphère cambridge analytica
je formule donc le souhait madame que
votre audition ce jour dans le cadre
d'un véritable tour du monde des
parlements qui vous a déjà conduit
devant le sénat américain la chambre des
communes britannique le parlement
européen et nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale soit ce matin soit pour nous
l'occasion de prendre encore mieux
conscience de la réalité de l' influence
et des méthodes du plus grand réseau
social du monde si facebook avait fait
preuve de davantage de transparence et
avait répondu aux nombreuses questions
légitimes des parlementaires que nous
sommes n'aurions peut-être pas accorder
la même importance à vos propos mais le
mur du silence que nous renvoient
facebook à chaque fois que nous posons
une question a créé chez nous une
véritable attente par rapport aux
témoignages de personnes comme vous qui
ont travaillé chez facebook avant de jeu
avant de poser quelques questions je
transmets la parole au président de la
commission des affaires européennes jean
françois
jeu le président de la commission de la
culture chez elle le rend le fond
[Musique]
mais chers collègues comme l'a rappelé
le président la foule au scandale qui
éclabousse facebook depuis quelques
semaines n'est que le dernier d'une
longue série mais pour la première fois
madame à horgen vos révélations s'appuie
non non pas seulement sur des constats
externe ou sur des témoignages
individuels mais sur des documents de
travail internes de facebook que vous
avez patiemment photographier puis
transmis au congrès américain et à la
security exchange commission le gendarme
de la bourse américaine au fil de
plusieurs milliers de pages se dévoile
ainsi l'effet néfaste des réseaux
sociaux sur la santé mentale des
adolescents ou sur la polarisation du
débat public vous êtes pourtant un pur
produit de la silicon valley vous y avez
effectué toute votre carrière dans de
grands groupes comme google interest et
enfin facebook où vous étiez en charge
de la lutte contre la désinformation
vous nous expliquerait ce qui vous a
poussé à prendre la décision courageuse
de devenir lanceuse d' alerte face à
l'une des entreprises les plus
puissantes du monde je tiens à vous
remercier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à venir témoigner au sénat la
commission des affaires européennes
examinera en effet dans quelques
semaines le rapport de nos collègues
catherine morin desailly et florence
blatrix compta sur le projet digital
services act européen
ce texte pionnier prévoir un régime de
responsabilité renforcée à l'égard des
plateformes afin d'empêcher la
prolifération des contenus illicites il
propose également des obligations
complémentaire pour les très grandes
plateformes concernant l'évaluation et
la gestion des risques systémiques
notamment la désinformation votre
témoignage ne sera donc particulièrement
précieux pour affûter étayer nos
positions sur ce texte à cet égard nous
serons particulièrement désireux de vous
entendre sur les ressources mises en
oeuvre par facebook
la modération y compris dans différentes
langues mais aussi par exemple sur la
gestion par facebook de la sécurité des
produits un sujet auquel la france est
particulièrement attentive au delà de
ces questions particulières nous
souhaiterions recueillir votre sentiment
sur le modèle commercial des plateformes
de réseaux sociaux les chèques dont vous
faites le constat est il la conséquence
d'un manque de volonté et de moyens de
la part de facebook ou les causes sont
bien plus profondes pensez-vous au fond
que ce modèle basé sur une économie de
l'attention est financé par la publicité
ciblée est réformable je vais vous
laisser la parole peut être
quelques temps avant que nous posions
des questions je vais rappeler à nos
collègues laurent lafon pourrait le
faire on a échangé nous avons jusqu'à
16h 40 puisque madame morgendois est
parti à 16h45 donc sur les questions
17h45 pardon 17h45 donc nous avons
jusque 17h40 je vis à l'ancienne heures
excusez moi et est donc et donc le temps
de questions sera court soyez brefs
soyez pragmatique pour qu'elle puisse
répondre question par question parce
qu'elle me l'a demandé
c'est à vous
[Musique]
monsieur
le président
mesdames et messieurs les centres sa
notice et laisse en tout cas
je vous remercie de l'opportunité qui
m'est donnée de me présenter devant vous
et de votre volonté de faire face à
certaines des menaces les plus urgence
urgente pour les citoyens français je
m'appelle francis à horgen je
travaillais chez facebook et j'avais
rejoint l'entreprise parce que je
croyais que facebook avait le potentiel
de faire ressortir le meilleur de nous
mais je suis ici aujourd'hui parce que
je crois que les produits de facebook
aux enfants aggrave les clivages
affaiblissent notre démocratie et bien
plus encore les dirigeants de
l'entreprise savent comment rendre
facebook et instagram plus sûres mais
ils refusent de faire les changements
nécessaires parce qu'ils font passer
leurs immenses bénéfices avant les gens
les conséquences sont graves
la plateforme facebook aujourd'hui
portent atteinte à la santé à la
sécurité de nos communautés et menacent
l'intégrité de nos démocraties
il ne sera pas facile de relever ce défi
mais les démocraties doivent faire ce
qu'elles ont toujours fait lorsque les
actions du commerce entre en conflit
avec les intérêts du peuple et de la
société dans son ensemble les
démocraties doivent intervenir et
élaborer de nouvelles lois je suis
reconnaissante au gouvernement français
de prendre cette question très au
sérieux et je suis heureuse que les
dirigeants français au sein de l'union
européenne comme le commissaire breton
prenne cela très au sérieux également
à mon avis
la loi sur les services numériques ds à
qui est actuellement examiné par le
parlement européen a le potentiel pour
devenir une référence mondiale qui
pourra inspirer d'autres pays y compris
le mien
à adopter de nouvelles règles qui
protégerait nos démocraties
mais la loi doit être forte
et son application ferme
sinon nous perdrons cette occasion
unique
d'aligner l'avenir de la technologie et
de la démocratie
je sais que les dirigeants français ont
joué un rôle central dans les progrès
que nous avons accomplis et je vous
encourage à maintenir la pression mon
analyse est mon explication des
documents dans ma ville question ne sont
pas uniquement basée sur mon travail à
facebook
je travaille comme chef de produit dans
de grandes entreprises technologiques
depuis 2006 y compris google print et
reste yelp et facebook mon travail a
surtout porté sur des produits
algorithmique comme les recherches
google + et des systèmes de
recommandations comme celui qui alimente
le fil d'actualité facebook
en travaillant dans ces quatre grandes
entreprises technologies qui exploite
différents types de réseaux sociaux j'ai
pu comparer et contrastées la façon dont
chaque entreprise aborde et relève
différents défis les choix opérés par
les dirigeants de facebook constitue un
problème énorme pour les enfants pour la
sécurité publique pour les démocraties
c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé l' alerte et
soyons clairs les choses n'ont pas à
être comme ça nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui à cause des choix délibéré
que facebook a fait
j'ai rejoint facebook en 2019 parce
qu'un de mes proches s'est radicalisée
je me suis senti obligé de jouer un rôle
actif dans une création d'un meilleur
facebook moins toxiques au cours de mon
travail chez facebook d'abord en tant
que chef de produit pour la
désinformation civique puis sur le
contre espionnage
facebook a fait à plusieurs reprises
des conflits entre ses propres bénéfices
et notre
un fait face à plusieurs reprises à des
conflits entre ses propres bénéfices et
notre sécurité et ils ont toujours
résolu ces conflits en faveur de leur
propre profit cela donnait un système
qui amplifie la division l'extrémisme la
polarisation qui fragilise les sociétés
dans le monde entier dans certains cas
ce dangereux discours en ligne a conduit
à des actes de violences qui ont fait
des victimes voire des morgues dans
d'autres cas leur machine à optimiser
les profits génère de l'automutilation
de la haine de soi notamment pour des
groupes vulnérables comme les
adolescentes ces problèmes ont été
confirmés à plusieurs reprises par les
recherches internes de facebook
il ne s'agit pas seulement de la colère
ou de l'instabilité de certains
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux
facebook est devenu une entreprise de
1000 milliards de dollars en engrangeant
des bénéfices aux dépens de notre
sécurité y compris celles de nos enfants
c'est inacceptable
je crois que j'ai fait ce qui était
juste et nécessaire pour l'intérêt
général mais je sais que facebook
dispose de ressources infinies qu'il
pourrait utiliser pour me détruire j'ai
lancé l' alerte parce que j'ai compris
une vérité effrayante presque personne
en dehors de facebook ne sait ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de facebook
la direction de l'entreprise cache des
informations vitales au public à ses
actionnaires au gouvernement américain
et aux gouvernements du monde entier
les documents que j'ai fourni prouve que
facebook nous on nous a trompés à
plusieurs reprises sur ce que ses
propres recherches révèlent sur la
sécurité des enfants
son rôle dans la diffusion de messages
haineux et polarisant et bien plus
encore
une réponse adaptée à cette urgence
serait de nouvelles règles et de
nouvelles normes la législation de l'ue
eu un énorme potentiel
elle n'essaie pas de supprimer le
problème avec des réglementations sur le
contenu elle adopte une approche neutre
en termes de contenu pour s'attaquer aux
risques systémiques et aux méfaits du
problème du modèle commercial global
je soutiens fermement cet acte et
je crois que la force des nouvelles lois
dépend de la volonté politique des états
membres pour s'assurer qu'elles sont
appliquées
il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur la
manière de résoudre les problèmes de
facebook et d'autres grandes entreprises
de plateformes
et les problèmes qu'ils posent à la
société et à la démocratie
je souhaite mettre en lumière deux
points qui d'après mon expérience sont
d'une importance capitale premièrement
demander des comptes aux entreprises
pour les préjudices sociaux qu'elle
provoque et deuxièmement établir de
nouvelles règles axés spécifiquement sur
le modèle commercial lui-même
au coeur des problèmes auxquels nous
sommes confrontés actuellement il ya le
fait que personne ne peut comprendre les
choix destructeur de facebook mieux que
facebook car seul facebook a le droit et
pardonnez moi l'expression de regarder
sous le capot facebook ne peut pas être
jury juges procureurs et témoin à la
fois
par conséquent
la transparence sera essentiel pour une
réglementation efficace il faudrait un
accent un accès complet aux données pour
les recherches n'ont dirigé par facebook
nous avons besoin de plus d'experts pour
étudier ces problèmes et ils doivent
avoir toutes les données dont ils ont
besoin pour le faire il est essentiel de
bien faire les choses et le diable sera
dans les détails
j'ai préconisé un plan en trois étapes
pour le processus d'évaluation des
risques
premièrement ça c'est pour l'entreprise
chaque plateforme
devrait être tenu responsable des
risques posés par ces produits et
services il devrait tout elles devraient
toutes être obligé de procéder à une
analyse de la sécurité des produits
divulguées publiquement deuxièmement ça
c'est la réglementation un régulateur
devrait sonder le public et les groupes
de la société civile pour comprendre
quels sont les angles morts que la
plateforme n'a pas examiné facebook est
homogène et géographiquement isolés nous
devons nous assurer que l'évaluation des
risques brosse un tableau complet de
tous les risques que posent un produit
troisièmement et ça c'est pour la
responsabilité les entreprises devraient
être tenues d'articuler un plan pour
traiter chaque préjudice ce plan devra
être auditées et contrôler pour
s'assurer qu'il est vraiment mis en
oeuvre nous avons besoin des données de
l'entreprise pour vérifier leurs progrès
facebook a démontré à maintes reprises
qu'elle tente d'aplanir les scandales en
déclarant simplement nous y travaillons
cette dynamique doit changer
cela commence par l'accès aux données
voici l'une des questions que je reçois
le plus souvent qu'elle donnait devons
nous demander à facebook
si un accès total aux données dont
dispose facebook permettrait d'effectuer
un large éventail de recherche il doit
être effectué avec précaution afin de
donner aux analystes ce dont ils ont
besoin tout en protégeant la vie privée
des utilisateurs
cet accès aux données et ce qui permet
aux chercheurs et aux régulateurs
d'évaluer les risques et les préjudices
de l'ensemble du système de profilage de
six plages et le in game and banking qui
est le classement basé sur l'engagement
l'épreuve contenus dans mes divulgation
montre clairement que les systèmes de
classement basé sur l'engagement ce and
games and banking sont l'une des causes
fondamentales de certains les plus
grands risques systémiques que les
réseaux sociaux font courir à nos
sociétés il s'agit d'un problème au
niveau du système lui même en utilisant
les outils neutre en terme de contenu
les nouvelles lois devrait obliger les
plateformes à assumer leurs
responsabilités non seulement sur la
divulgation de contenus illégaux mais
aussi sur la manipulation des élections
la diffusion virale de la désinformation
les effets néfastes sur la santé mentale
des jeunes et des adolescents si la
nouvelle législation est bien conçu elle
peut changer la donne dans le monde vous
pouvez obliger les plateformes à
intégrer le risque sociétale dans leurs
activités commerciales de sorte que les
décisions concernant les produits à
développer et la manière de les
développer ne soit plus fondée
uniquement sur la maximisation des
bénéfices vous pouvez établir des règles
des normes systémique qui tienne compte
des risques tout en prenant en compte la
liberté d'expression et vous pouvez
montrer au monde comment la transparence
la surveillance et l'application des
règles fonctionner nous avons déjà vu
cela quand les fabricants de tabac a
affirmé que les cigarettes avec filtre
était plus sûr pour les consommateurs
les scientifiques ont pu invalider ce
message marketing en confirmant qu'en
fait elle posait toujours une menace
sérieuse à la santé humaine et qu'elle
était en fait plus toxique que les
autres cigarettes mais aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons pas faire ce type
d'évaluation de facebook indépendante
nous devons tout bonnement croire que ce
que dit facebook est vrai et ils ont
prouvé à plusieurs reprises qu'il ne
mérite pas notre confiance aveugle les
régulateurs de facebook peuvent voir
certains des problèmes mais ils restent
aveugles quant à leur cause ils ne
peuvent donc pas élaboré de solutions
spécifiques ils ne peuvent pas d'avoir
accès aux données de l'entreprise sur la
sécurité des produits encore moins mener
un audit indépendant comment est ce que
le public est censé déterminer si
facebook résout les conflits d'intérêt
de manière conforme à l'intérêt général
si il n'a aucune visibilité et aucun
contexte sur le fonctionnement réel de
facebook cela doit changer chers
sénateurs et sénatrices l'enjeu est de
taille vous avez cette opportunité
unique de créer de nouvelles règles pour
le monde en ligne
un réseau social plus sûres et plus
agréables est possible
si vous ne deviez retenir que 2.2 mais
divulgation les voici dû premièrement
facebook choisi chaque jour le profit au
détriment de la sécurité et sans actions
énergiques des législateurs cela
continuera deuxièmement facebook
exploite sa capacité à cacher le
comportement réel de la plate forme pour
permettre à notre sécurité de se
dégrader à un niveau inacceptable
si facebook est autorisé à continuer à
fonctionner dans l'obscurité nous ne
verrons que des tragédies croissante par
conséquence j'ai lancé l' alerte aux
risques de ma vie parce que je crois
qu'il y a encore le temps d'agir
mais nous devons agir maintenant merci
merci madame pour votre du ctif très
forts qui vont
j'imagine soulevé un certain nombre de
questions je commençais à vous poser des
questions très précises pour comprendre
le fonctionnement de facebook où vous
avez dit à l'instant même que personne
ne connaît facebook 6t facebook et pour
aider à notre compréhension je vais vous
poser des questions très précises
d'abord sur la question fondamentale de
la modération sur lequel nous mêmes nous
avons interrogé mgr reprises les
responsables de facebook vous avoir
aucune réponse précise nous nous
interrogeons bien sûr sur le nombre de
modérateur francophones qui suivent tous
les propos en français est-ce que vous
avez un ordre de grandeur si ce n'est un
chiffre précis du nombre de modérateur
francophones qui agissent partout dans
le monde est-ce que c'est inférieur à
100 personnes à 500 personnes mille
personnes est ce que vous pourriez nous
donner une indication sur ses
modérateurs gens posent une deuxième
parce qu'elle est liée est la presse à
plusieurs et à plusieurs reprises a fait
état que ces modérateurs étaient en fait
des prestataires extérieurs il n'y avait
pas de modérateur interne à facebook est
souvent le cas
une des raisons pour lesquelles facebook
ne divulgue pas cela pour les
modérateurs français frau francophone
c'est parce que il y en a trop peu donc
je ne sais pas quel est le chiffre exact
du nombre de nos modérateurs mais je
sais que en septembre 2020 donc c'était
il ya un an il dépensait 87 % du budget
opérationnel donc c'est pas le budget
d'ingénierie mais le budget opérationnel
pour les opérations des pays sur
l'anglais
et je ne sais pas exactement comment ces
ventilé je ne sais pas quand ce qui est
sûr la modération sur ce qui est sûr la
vérification de fait mais je pense que
quand on sait quand on sait qu'ils ont
trente mille modérateur
je pense que trois quarts d'entre eux
sont pour l'anglais
facebook c'est que la plus grosse menace
pour l'entreprise c'est si quelque chose
devient toxique aux états unis et ils
ont sous investi là où ils ne se sentent
pas menacés
quant aux prestataires extérieurs il y a
des usines facebook de par le monde je
pense que c'est principalement aux
philippines
on a la plupart des modérateurs qui sont
basés aux philippines et bien sûr la
plupart sont anglophones mais je ne suis
pas sûre et facebook garde ces personnes
en tant que prestataire parce qu'il est
beaucoup moins d'obligations attaché à
ses prestataires mais je pense que ceux
qui font les vérifications les la
modération sont principalement des
prestataires extérieurs effectivement
deuxième série de questions cette fois
ci sur l'organisation interne dans
facebook et entre le sur le lien entre
le siège et les services aux etats-unis
et les entités qui sont dans les
différents pays et singulièrement en
europe quelle est l'autonomie des
entités facebook dans chacun des pays
est ce qu'ils peuvent intervenir sur les
algorithmes
dans quelle mesure les entités sur place
influent sur les modérations pour
prendre en compte les différences
culturel social entre les pays et
adapter les règles de modération
d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre c'est
que les normes sont assez similaires
d'un pays à l'autre avec des exceptions
notamment sur la nudité qui sont très
spécifiques culturellement et expliquent
généralement là les deux les deux la
polarité entre l'arabie saoudite et la
suède pour expliquer cela en général je
pense que il n'ya pas de spécificité par
pays sauf s'il ya vraiment une règle une
législation
différente
et je pense que la stratégie facebook
part du principe qu'il faut soutenir des
choses par langue plutôt que d'avoir la
plateforme sécurisée dans son ensemble
ça bien sûr des limites parce que les
systèmes ne sont pas conçus pour être
adapté pour l'algérie un front
francophone le français algérien où le
français de france où le français
d'ailleurs dans le monde et ce n'est pas
efficace de de customiser pour les plus
petits marchés pour l'autonomie il ya
très peu d'autonomie
pour les les classements des fils
d'actualité par exemple j'ai jamais vue
de rapports d'un officier pays je n'ai
jamais vu quand je travaillais à la
désinformation civiques et pour moi je
travaillais uniquement sur la
désinformation en dehors des états unis
portent enfin sur une remarque que vous
avez fait ce matin à propos de
l'anonymat vous avez dit je vous cite
vous seriez surpris de savoir ce qu'ils
peuvent sur facebook faire grâce au wifi
par exemple est ce que vous pourriez
préciser un peu ce que vous entendez et
qu'est-ce que quel type d'information
d'entreprise comme facebook utilise à
partir des données wifi
alors je suis pour des entreprises comme
google
ils contrôlent les noms des réseaux
autour de vous pour voir exactement où
vous êtes c'est pour cela qu'il pourrait
être si précis dans la localisation sur
une carte je sais que facebook à six
différents systèmes pour vous localiser
à n'importe quel moment
c'est ça s'appelle votre empreinte
digitale lot de localisation votre
localisation d'un 2
et je pense qu
il enregistre le nom de votre wifi je ne
me suis pas sûr à 100% mais je pense
qu'il ya suffisamment de systèmes qu'ils
peuvent raffiné suffisamment les données
pour savoir exactement où vous êtes
je vais demander rapporteur de
commission des affaires européennes sur
ces questions des médias en particulier
catherine morin desailly et florent ce
blatrie ce qu'on t'a
un grand merci vous êtes le deuxième
lanceur d' alerte avec votre compatriote
edouard snowdon à avoir alerté les
opinions au niveau mondial du fait que
l'internet n'était pas le monde
angélique que l'on pouvait penser au
démarrage donc merci infiniment
votre témoignage et est extrêmement
précieux à l'heure où avec ma collègue
florence béatrice compta nous sommes en
train de travailler à ce rapport sur le
dge le savez cet acte pour lequel vous
avez été aussi auditionné à aa à
bruxelles alors votre constat qui est
accablant n'est pas franchement une
surprise pour les sénateurs et les
sénatrices pourquoi parce que depuis la
sphère cambridge en haïti cas on avait
bien identifier les dysfonctionnements
la manipulation des données de plus de
83 millions
d'internautes et nous avions bien mesuré
qu'au sein de l'entreprise il y a eu il
y avait des alertes comme vous vous en
avez formulées et qu'elle n'avait pas
été écouté vous avez le courage de
témoigner devant congrès américain et au
parlement européen ce que n'a pas fait
en effet mark
zuckerber la sphère du capitole nous a
aussi alerté sur les menaces faites à
notre démocratie par les réseaux
sociaux donc oui plus de transparence
plus de redevabilité 40 mobility pour
bien entendu c'est ces plateformes mais
au-delà de ça il nous faut légiférer
dans un cadre européen car nous avons eu
des tentatives de législations
nationales mais elles se sont avérées
des échecs pourquoi parce qu'elle
mettait en danger finalement la liberté
d'expression dans un mauvais équilibre
et une mauvaise compréhension de ce
qu'étaient les écosystèmes tels que vous
l'avez démontré alors notre
préoccupation dans ma collègue et moi
sera une première question qu'on va
aussi se partager l'ensemble des
questions c'est de comprendre
l'écosystème
le modèle économique que vous avez
évoquées
notamment vous êtes en zone est une
spécialiste le fonctionnement de ces
algorithmes ses algorithmes ont ils été
conçu en a besoin d'avoir une réponse
extrêmement précises dans cette
intention originel de faire
exclusivement du profite du profit
auquel cas peuvent-ils être corrigé si
oui comment et par qui ou bien est-ce
complètement irréparable auquel cas le
modèle économique et comme l'a dit
social à zubov dans son livre
capitaliser s'oriente toxiques est
définitivement pervers ça c'est une
question fondamentale pour nous pour
comprendre le système et puisque vous
avez parlé d'évaluation et
d'identification des risques systémiques
et d'un vaste plan serait nécessaire
pour justement mesurer tout cela
vous savez que l'article 31 du desa
prévoit l'ouverture des données
nécessaires à des chercheurs extérieurs
a pas de facebook extérieur pour évaluer
cela mais qu on opposera peut-être le
secret des affaires pouvez vous nous
confirmer s'il est absolument
indispensable qu en effet tous assez
ouvert à une évaluation
expertise extérieure pour que ça puisse
marcher voilà déjà deux questions assez
précises et avec que florence matrix
content on va poursuivre merci
[Musique]
l'intention de générer des bénéfices
facebook a fait un changement en 2018
passant du temps passé en optimisant le
temps sur le cul pour lequel il pouvait
vous garder sur le site en optimisant
l'interaction sociale qui a du sens
donc on appelle vraiment cela
interactions parce que ce qu'ils
appellent meaningful c'est à dire qu'il
ya du sang ça peut être du harcèlement
ça peut être d'autre chose et oui ils
appellent ça qui a du sens bref six mois
après ce lancement
ils ont vu que les fils avaient moins de
sens donc voilà on oublie l'idée que
c'était pour augmenter le sens là leur
volonté c'était de générer davantage de
contenu quand les gens en génère plus de
contenu on reste plus longtemps sur le
site et on consomme plus de publicité si
c'est le modèle commercial ils ont
essayé différentes choses et ceux qui
celui qui avait le moins d'effets
secondaires c'était de donner beaucoup
plus de petits ipsen de petites
récompenses de dopamine avec de partage
de commentaire par exemple facebook
n'avait pas l'intention
de faire partir cet incendie mais ils
voient ils ont réalisé que plus les
cliques arriver vite plus il y avait de
colère est-ce que ça peut être fixée oui
ça peut être réparé ça peut être fixé
facebook connaît énormément de solutions
des solutions qui fonctionnerait partout
dans le monde pas juste sur certaines
langues ou en choisissant entre des
bonnes idées et des mauvaises idées il y
à des modifications à faire sur la plate
forme
parce que ce n'est pas une question de
mauvaise personne ou de mauvaise idée
c'est ainsi il s'agit d'un système qui y
perd amplifie les mauvais les pires
contenu on avait une version de facebook
en 2008 où on avait un d'actualité qui
était sur la famille et les amis et on
ne parlait pas de la destruction de la
démocratie à l'époque le nouveau système
chez spie pousse les personnes poussent
vraiment les personnes dans des groupes
énorme des groupes qui par inadvertance
sont des groupes beaucoup plus extrêmes
parce que eux aussi
fonctionne avec ce classement par
engagement c'est pour cela qu'il ya eu
ce scandale en allemagne on a vu que 65%
des personnes qui rejoignent des groupes
nazis les rejoignent et parce que il
avait été suggéré par facebook
et donc wyeth à cette question mais
pourquoi ils n'ont pas réparer cela et
bien c'est là que le modèle commercial
intervient sans
avoir une force qui les y oblige comme
le ds à ils vont continuer à ne pas
développer ces changements là ne pas
déployer ces changements parce que
chacun représente des bénéfices 0 1% à 0
5% et 1% à chaque fois il pourrait avoir
90 % - de désinformation demain sur la
plate forme mais ça leur coûtera
quelques points de pourcentage de
bénéfices et donc la question qu'on doit
poser c'est est ce que facebook mérite
d'avoir 35 % 40 % de marge de bénéfice
ou même 25 % c'est la question là qu'on
doit poser on ne leur dit pas de ne pas
être rentable on leur demande d'être
responsable et enfin il est d'importance
vitale pour que les
universitaires et que les chercheurs
indépendants aient accès aux données
je défend l'accès ouvert pour les
chercheurs indépendants et les
universitaires et d'avoir un accès plus
étendue aux données agrégées
ces grains crise car la donne est
consciente de la vie privée parce que
pour twitter par exemple on a dix mille
chercheurs indépendants comme moi par
exemple qui peuvent regarder les données
publiques de twitter donc 1 à 10 tweets
peuvent aller vers n'importe qui et
c'est une question de sécurité nationale
parce qu'une fraction des informations
attrapé par facebook ont été attrapés
par ce que des chercheurs indépendants
les ont trouvés sur twitter et ensuite
les ont cartographié les ont ramenés
vers facebook donc on doit avoir un
écosystème de responsabilité c'est comme
ça qu'on peut contrebalancer le poids de
ces plateformes merci
merci messieurs les présidents morgen
merci pour votre courage
dans le prolongement de la question de
ma collègue sur les algorithmes
finalement est-ce que les algorithmes
peuvent
être conçus de manière responsable pour
fonctionner au bénéfice de tous et pour
quelles raisons les algorithmes de
fonctionne t-il pas de manière
responsable est simple problème de parme
de paramétrage seulement est ce le fruit
de leur utilisation et en conséquence
est ce que vous pensez que mettre en
place des obligations de legacy by
design pour les algorithmes soit utile
et
ensuite une question sur sur le modèle
économique est ce que vous pensez que
des mesures qui visent à l'assèchement
des ruches des ressources publicitaires
des plateformes liées aux contenus
illégaux de désinformation pourrait
avoir un impact et le modèle économique
de facebook finalement pour est il selon
vous continuer à fonctionner si on
interdisait la publicité ciblée et
finalement dans le prolongement de de
ski a indiqué le président jean françois
rapin
nous avons
en europe une réglementation stricte en
matière de protection des données
personnelles le rg qui entrait en
vigueur en 2018 à votre connaissance ce
texte at il réellement un impact sur la
manière dont facebook prêtes les données
personnelles de nos concitoyens merci
[Musique]
on nous croit
sans aucun doute les algorithmes peuvent
être faits avec safety design de manière
sûre le problème à l'heure actuelle
c'est que la seule incitations cas
facebook c'est c'est le bénéfice ce sont
les bénéfices la plupart des grosses
entreprises de technologie ont une
certaine transparence pour google on
peut télécharger les résultats de
recherche et c'est ce que font les gens
on peut les analyser et google c'est
qu'ils sont
contrôlés et donc ils sont plus
responsables ils ont des vrais
ingénieurs qui travaillent sur le
système qui est qui écrivent des blogs
et qui explique comment fonctionne la
recherche depuis 2006 au moins quand moi
je travaillais chez eux twitter c'est
également que les gens récupèrent un
dixième des tweets et les analyses et
donc je pense qu'ils font des choix plus
responsables a par conséquent parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent être
tenus pour responsables facebook a
intentionnellement jamais fourni ces
informations sur leur système parce
qu'il pourrait être comme twitter et
partager leurs données et parce qu'ils
savent que si on ne voit rien si on est
en aveugle alors on ne peut pas poser de
questions alors on ne peut pas demander
de nouvelles règles on peut intervenir
et dire oui il réfléchissait à la
sécurité publique
à l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas une
question de périmètre
c'est une question de quand les
personnes voient des problèmes comment
gérer ces problèmes parce qu'il ya
vraiment deux facebook via le facebook
de la croissance qui est l'eau
l'optimiste voir qu'est ce qu'ils font
de biens et les personnes sur la sécu
qui s'occupe de sécurité sont
séparés à la avant ils travailler
uniquement sur empêcher que le site
ne crache maintenant il travaille un
petit peu sur l'âme et informations mais
à chaque fois que personne trouve une
solution
qui rend le système plus sûr mais que ça
c'est aux dépens des profits alors ils
ont la pression pour ne pas le mettre en
place il faut donc changer les
incitations de l'entreprise parce qu'ils
ont des solutions à l'heure actuelle qui
n'impose rien qu'on à l'encontre de la
liberté d'expression mais ils
choisissent de ne pas les mettre en
place parce que cela leur coûte certaine
proportion de leurs
de leurs bénéfices
beaucoup d'entreprises ont géré leur
manière de stocker des données grâce aux
rg et de grosses sociétés google par
exemple je sais que il y a également les
abus sur le verger parce que facebook
a dit ah non on ne peut pas vous donner
des données à cause du rgp des donc
voilà il faut bien s'assurer qu'ils ont
inclus des définitions de vie privée
dans le dessein parce que si on n'est
pas clair et qu'on demande et qu'on dit
que les données agrégées ne ne viole pas
la vie privée par exemple eh bien je
pense que ça permettra à éviter que
facebook l'utilisent comme une excuse
par rapport à la publicité
oui je pense que facebook pour être
rentable sans ces publicités ciblées
est-ce qu'il serait aussi rentable
qu'aujourd'hui certainement pas et donc
encore une fois c'est la question est
une question d'équilibré entre
différents besoins je ne suis pas
économiste je ne peux pas vous dire
combien ils perdraient mais j'imagine
les publicités non ciblés sont quand
même rentable et facebook à d'autres
manières de faire de l'argent par
ailleurs donc voilà je pense qu'ils ont
suffisamment d'options
toute dernière question en tant que co
inventeur
votre cible c'est vraiment la jeunesse
vous voulez aussi
prémunir la jeunesse des effets
désastreux que vous avez évoqué de de
facebook mais finalement la jeunesse
elle n'est peut-être plus de temps sur
facebook que sur instagram là on sait qu
instagram c'est aussi facebook en
réalité c'est la même société facebook
whatsapp instagram pouvez vous nous dire
si instagram fonctionne de la même
manière et si vous formuler les mêmes
remarques pour instagram et pression qu
aurait l'air faut-il ou non envisagées
comme sapin démocrate américain en parle
maintenant des politiques et mc cain le
démantèlement voilà du trust
[Musique]
une des raisons pour lesquelles je ne
soutiens pas le démantèlement de ce 13
qu'on vous le dit c'est parce que c'est
à cause de ses problèmes de plateformes
qui existe dans les deux services avec
ce in game and banking qui est au coeur
des problèmes pour les deux systèmes et
dans leurs produits on voit les mêmes
problèmes
donc les documents dans ma divulgation
montre que le comment le clown tik tok
d'instagram briggs a les mêmes problèmes
avec l'algorithme qui n'étaient pas
programmés pour être raciste mais qui a
appris
que en mettant des contenus noir
ça ne fonctionnait pas aussi bien par
exemple donc ce n'est pas le problème de
l'entreprise en soi c'est un problème de
l'intelligence artificielle qui n'a pas
de contrebalancer qui force l'entreprise
de gérer les choses de cette manière
donc si facebook doit faire un choix
on va mettre dix mille nouveaux
ingénieurs sur des jeux vidéo plutôt que
dix mille nouveaux ingénieurs dans la
sécurité parce que à l'heure actuelle
ils ne veulent que des bénéfices ils
veulent trouver une nouvelle entreprise
rentable plutôt que de sécuriser leurs
produits actuels alors les problèmes
continueront dans les deux entreprises
dans les deux branches de la société
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir le bon contrôle et cela changera
la relation des de l'entreprise avec le
public le public
[Musique]
alors là nos collègues en leur demandant
d compris le temps et non limitée d'être
le plus concis et rapide possible pierre
auzias merci monsieur le président merci
madame pour votre travail la qualité de
vos informations vous êtes citoyenne des
états unis d'amérique pays d'origine de
facebook et vous comprenez que nous
français on a un problème supplémentaire
avec cette entreprise c'est celle de la
défense de notre indépendance nationale
la question c'est de savoir si nous
allons continuer à être une colonie
numérique des gars femmes et si ces
entreprises vont accroître leur maîtrise
sont nos données personnelles au risque
d'intervenir directement dans le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie alors
que même elle échappe à toute forme de
régulation et de contrôle des
institutions notre gouvernement ici en
france à proposer quelques quelques lois
qui ont été malheureusement sans effet
je prends juste un exemple le conseil
supérieur de l'audivisuel peut en
principe accéder aux algorithmes les
gars fans ne lui donne pas et comme il
n'y a pas
deux dispositifs de contrôle il n'y a
aucune aucune possibilité de les obtenir
vous l'avez dit très justement
la violence de facebook est
consubstantiel de son modèle numérique
aussi je pense que on veut pas
s'intéresser à ce problème sans toucher
à ce modèle numérique est ici au sénat
nous avions travaillé à un amendement
qui prenait l'inter opérabilité
c'est-à-dire qui permettait aux usagers
de garder la maîtrise de leurs données
tout en leur permettant de changer de
plateforme donc c'était introduire une
forme de de concurrence est ce que vous
pensez qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une
musique utiles pour réduire le monopole
de facebook je vous remercie
salut
pour répondre à votre première question
j'adore ce terme que vous utilisez de
deux colonies et numériques v bref aux
états unis on a ce terme pas de taxation
sans représentation
parfois
on peut compter on pourrait compter
toutes les tous les dollars qui sont
représentés par la publicité générée
par l'europe j'ai travaillé sur google+
je sais combien ça représente vous avez
des options
peut-être que parfois il faut regarder
un petit peu le retour sur
investissement bref il ya également des
questions de défense nationale dans les
tendances nationales parce que facebook
à se cache il y a ceux plus gros fardeau
parce que personne d'autre ne peut
intervenir sur sa sécurité j'ai
travaillé sur le conte contre-espionnage
et j'ai aidé à mettre en place des
outils
1 contre le terrorisme et cartel le
trafic humain l'exploitation d'enfants
et
les crimes en ligne il est inacceptable
que vous ne sachiez pas combien de
personnes travaillent dans chacune de
ses fonctions c'est inacceptable qu'on
ne sache pas combien d'affaires sont
prises en charge dans chacun de ces
domaines par pays parce que je pense que
vous seriez choqué
sur le peu qui est fait pour protéger la
france et c'est complètement
inacceptable
deuxième question sur l'interopérabilité
pour revenir à sur ce premier point le
dsi doit demander cette divulgation ils
doivent articulé quelles zones sont
importantes et combien de personnes
travaillent dans chaque domaine et kehl
quand je travaillais chez google l'un
des points que google faisait pour faire
comme si plus de femmes travailler dans
les postes techniques c'est qu'il
incluait les secrétaires des ingénieurs
et qui les mettait dans le personnel
technique si on avait demandé les titres
exact est pas le nombre de personnes
alors je pense qu'on serait dit ouais
bon peut-être pas cette personne du coup
question suivante sur l'interopérabilité
l'interopérabilité je pense
ouvre d'autres difficultés qui
pourraient plus compliqué que les
problèmes actuels donc imaginer par
exemple qu'on conçoit tous
des serveurs gmail les emails ont cette
interopérabilité si vous voulez être un
serveur d'e-mails et que vous voulez
avoir différents clients email vous
pouvez le faire mais le contraint par
e-mail sais que si je vous envoie un
email dès qu'il quitte mon application
mon client
alors je ne gère plus je ne peux plus le
rappeler je me suis engagé
et il ne va pas aller vers tous les
serveurs du mail il va vers un seul
serveur on a sept lignes privées
imaginez un monde où chacun d'entre vous
représentera un clown facebook
imaginez que je suis sur facebook mais
que mes amis sont tous sur des clones et
il ya peut-être quelques amis sur chacun
de vos serveurs imaginons que je poste
une photo de mon bébé mon bébé qui vient
de naître
il ne va pas aller sur un serveur qui
comme un email il va aller vers tous les
serveurs individuellement et je dois
avoir confiance que vous êtes tous de
bons acteurs que vous n'avez pas été
fondée par un groupe russe par exemple
le deuxième enjeu c'est imaginer ça fait
deux ans le contrat qu'on a aujourd'hui
pour les réseaux sociaux c'est que après
avoir posté quelque chose
on a le droit de changer
les paramètres de sécurité par exemple
on se dit bon il ya trop de monde qui
peut le voir je ne veux plus que ce soit
visible pas mais tombe dans deux ans je
ne veux plus que mes enfants soient en
ligne je ne me sens pas je ne sens pas
sûr peut-être que j'ai une dispute avec
leur père par exemple et que les
informations sur les 1 les enfants
pourrait me faire perdre
mes enfants et donc je dois avoir
confiance quand j'enlève mes photos de
mon serveur qu'elles seront enlevées de
tous les autres serveurs et ça voudra
dire que les gouvernements devront
audités chaque serveur individuellement
parce que si les photos de mon enfant ne
sont pas enlevées et que on a une
demande rogatoire à ce moment là
si je suis poursuivi je pourrais perdre
le le droit de garde de mes enfants par
exemple donc il ya des effets énormes
des effets réseaux qui sont incassables
il y a trois ans il y avait des pays
dans le monde qui avait d alternative à
facebook des réseaux qui était arrivé
suffisamment tôt qui avait suffisamment
de pénétration qui avait réussi à
exclure facebook mais aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus d'autres pays à part la chine qui
a interdit facebook et donc je pense
qu'il ya vraiment cette question que
quand on appelle un téléphone par
exemple on n'a pas besoin de demander
est ce que c'est un numéro de téléphone
qui vient d'une entreprise de téléphone
anciennes ou nouvelles on n'a pas
différents numéros de téléphone et je
pense que pour les réseaux sociaux
personnels qui sont différents des
réseaux sociaux publié et publier c'est
par exemple tik tok sur tik tok un
créateur créé parce qu'ils veulent
atteindre le plus de personnes possible
et au final les marchés peuvent être en
concurrence parce que les personnes
clown copie le contenu et les mettre
dans d'autres cibles par exemple je
regarde du contenu tik tok sur youtube
parce que les créateurs copie le contenu
sur youtube sur les réseaux sociaux
personnels par contre on ne veut pas
atteindre le plus de gens possible on
veut atteindre quelques personnes
spécifiques et c'est là qu'est la
difficulté et donc je vous encourage à
réfléchir à facebook comme un
prestataire public parce qu'il n'y a pas
le choix soit on les interdisent
complètement soit on accepte facebook
là dessus
oui merci monsieur le président merci
madame votre courage et puis l'apport
extrêmement utile dos de vos témoignages
pour le débat public et qui met en
exergue un peu la fragilité nos
démocraties il avait ses poids lourds du
numérique moi je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur la régulation des
algorithmes de recommandations puisque
vous l'avez expliqué c'est aussi ses
algorithmes qui sont le coeur du modèle
économique de facebook mais aussi le le
moteur d'un certain nombre de menaces
que vous avez bien décrit pour nos
démocraties
moi j'ai deux questions est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est possible de que la
puissance publique puisse réellement
obtenir la transparence de ses
algorithmes puisque facebook a déjà
menti à nombreuses reprises sur sur
certaines choses et y compris devant la
puissance publique et puis que ça fait
partie de leur modèle économique donc
ils vont avoir forcément une envie de
garder ça veut priver et puis vous avez
aussi rappelé dans vos différentes
interventions que les intelligences
artificielles et ne peuvent pas tout et
qui font un stand de moyens humains
notamment pour la modération donc moi ma
question ça serait sûr sur les moyens
humains qu'il faudrait à quelle échelle
il faudrait les évaluer
pour constituer un vrai service européen
de régulation indépendant qui devient
nécessaire comme vous l'avez démontré et
à l'échelle évidemment européenne
puisque c'est à mon avis la meilleure
échelle pour avoir ce service de de
régulation aulas
concernant
les données et les mensonges de facebook
sur leur donner je pense qu'il ya deux
avenues à explorer tout d'abord
dans l'évaluation des risques je vous ai
parlé de cela dans mon plan pour
l'entreprise pour la communauté et pour
la responsabilité également je pense
qu'il est plus simple
d'articuler les préjudices et de dire
voilà les données dont on a besoin pour
vérifier si vous faites des progrès donc
en tant que scientifique des données me
croyez moi c'est plus simple d'obtenir
les données de cette manière je pense
qu'il est important dans le ds à deux
mètres que quand facebook fournit des
données ils ne peuvent pas juste vous
remettre des données ils doivent
également divulgué
publié la manière dont ils ont produit
ces données la raison pour laquelle
c'est si important c'est que facebook
danse avec les données mieux que
quiconque dans le monde ils ont recruté
certains des meilleurs scientifiques de
données dans le monde et la nature de la
science des données c'est que chaque
calcul a besoin de simplification et de
suppositions
quand ils n'ont pas à vous montrer
comment ils ont créé ces données donc
c'est une requête sur est donc dans leur
registre quand ils n'ont pas besoin de
vous montrer il le cache il y a eu un
scandale aux etats unis
il ya deux mois ou des universitaires
avaient passé des années à demander des
données simples
et ils ont attrapé les mensonges de
facebook aux prêtres les universitaires
parce que il avait donné un set de
données il y avait 1
et les nouvelles données ne s'alignait
pas avec le set précédent l'idée qu'on
doit sans arrêt vérifier là où ils
mentent est complètement inacceptable
s'ils doivent dire comment ils ont créé
ces données alors je pense que vous avez
de meilleures chances
d'obtenir les bonnes données parce que
elle pourrait elle pour la peut être
contrôlé deuxième point quand vous avez
un système comme avec audit 1 2 3 ou
chaque préjudice à des données
associées alors c'est plus difficile de
créer des fausses données faire de vrai
de très bonnes fausses données est
extrêmement difficile
c'est un art et donc
si on va au delà de l'estimation mais on
veut de vraies 7 de données et qui ne
sont pas vraiment des données sensibles
d'un point de vue le vie privée mais qui
peuvent être des données agrégées alors
on peut faire des vérifications croisées
et c'est bien mieux au niveau de la
sécurité ensuite vous avez demandé le
nombre le moyen humain je pense que la
modération de contenu avec des humains
sera suffisant pour s'adresser aux
problèmes actuels et je pense qu'il y
aura le même problème avec la diversité
de langues ou nous aurons besoin
d'énormément de personnes dont
énormément de langues différentes et
dans les endroits les plus fragiles du
monde ce sera difficile d'avoir des
personnes qui auront les bonnes
compétences ou des responsables qui
pourront parler suffisamment de langue
pour gérer une équipe avec eux tout
multilingue et donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut sécuriser les plateformes et bien
plâtre facebook c'est que quand ils vous
montrent plus de contenu de votre
famille et de vos amis gratuitement
alors vous avez beaucoup moins de
discours haineux de nudité de violence
ce n'est pas une question de mauvaise
personne de mauvais contenus
facebook qui vous pousse à rejoindre des
groupes énorme des groupes de milliers
de personnes ou vous avez des milliers
de contenu créé par jour avec ses
usines qui crée le contenu et le contenu
qui va vers des milliers de personnes et
le pire des contenus parce que
l'algorithme choisit toujours l'alcool
le contenu le plus clivant et le plus
violent donc
choisir cette avenue de l'hyper
amplification même si certains dépôts de
contenus sont mauvais et ils
vont moins partout et ils sont moins
envoyé partout dans le monde et sera
moins d'impact
là où les contenus sont mauvais
individuellement
yann chanterelles
merci monsieur le président merci pour
votre intervention je pense que ça a été
beaucoup dit mais qu'il est essentiel de
le souligner à nouveau souligner votre
courage et votre détermination votre
présence ici
souligne aussi l'urgence qu'il ya pour
nous en tant que législateur de soutenir
les lanceurs et les lanceuses d' alerte
comme vous de mieux protéger votre
statut le statut pour qu'il y en ait
plus justement et votre intervention
finalement à met en lumière trois enjeux
essentiels qui doivent nous préoccuper
sur la question des médias sociaux plus
généralement c'est celui de la santé
publique notamment la santé mentale et
la protection des mineurs il ya celui de
la sécurité à l'heure où les discours de
haine du monde virtuel se transforment
en actes de violence dans le monde réel
on l'a vu avec le capitole aux états
unis qui a été attaqué celui de la
démocratie face aux manipulations aussi
et à désinformation sujet auquel nous
sommes particulièrement sensibles en
france à l'heure où on va vivre une
élection présidentielle en réponse à
cela vous mettez finalement le doigt sur
deux points éminemment politique
justement pour notre assemblée le
premier c'est que face à ces mastodontes
comme comme facebook qui font primer
finalement il a été très bien dit
auparavant les profits financiers sur
toute autre considération
notamment la protection de ses
utilisateurs la puissance publique doit
jouer son rôle pour réguler leur
activité justement et imposer des normes
deuxième c'est qu'en démocratie la
transparence et la responsabilité
doivent s'imposer aux entreprises
privées comme aux instances publiques et
que ces entreprises doivent rendre des
comptes alors pour faire court j'ai
justement de deux questions dans votre
intervention vous avez souligné à quel
point les outils de facebook les
algorithmes le classement des
publications étaient plus
particulièrement biaisée à l'endroit des
publics vulnérables
c'est une accusation très grave est à
mon sens pas assez souligné qu'ils
méritent qu'on s'y attarde est ce que
vous pourriez nous en dire plus à la
fois sur ses billets et sur les
populations qu'elles vous pensé quand
vous parlez de public vulnérable après
ensuite vous en avez également un peu à
parler vous êtes ici entre autres au
sein aussi la commission culture à
laquelle j'appartiens et nous sommes
très attachés à la richesse des langues
et des cultures est la défense de la
diversité face à toute hégémonie sme
culturel qu'ils soient américains
anglophones ou autre pourriez-vous
expliquer dans quelles proportions
justement les utilisateurs de facebook
en français mais pas uniquement ça peut
être en espagnol en arabe dialectal ou à
toute autre langue sont davantage
exposés face à la nocivité de certains
de ses outils que les utilisateurs
anglophones ou occidentaux en général et
une question plus subsidiaire mais
malgré tout sérieuse après cette
audition la plupart des parlementaires
vont eux-mêmes certainement faire un
post facebook pour pour relater nos
échanges pensez vous que l'algorithme de
ce facebook le mettra en avant par
exemple
[Musique]
quant aux populations vulnérables je
vais vous donner des exemples
facebook à regarder qui étaient les
personnes les plus à risque d'être hyper
exposé à la désinformation facebook a
découvert qu'il y avait trois critères
qui vous rendez plus hyper exposable
c'est d'être récemment veuf ou veuve
récemment divorcée et récemment ayant
déménagé parce que vous êtes plus
isolées socialement et facebook est là
pour vous connecter et vous continuez à
faire défiler l'écran et des fois
les personnes sont happés et il consomme
énormément de contenu parce qu'ils ont
perdu leur réseau social réel un autre
exemple des personnes vulnérables ces
sont les personnes qui sont encore une
fois ap et je pense que c'est assez
intéressant de contraste et facebook va
vous dire non ce tapage n'est pas réel
les gens sont exposés à différentes
opinions dans les réseaux sociaux mais
il faut vraiment faire la différence
entre des expériences à la marge et
l'expérience au coeur pour la plupart
des utilisateurs peut-être qu'ils font
face à différentes expositions
effectivement mais on sait que pour
pratiquement tous types de préjudice le
préjudice est surconcentré sur une
minorité d'utilisateurs je vais vous
donner l'exemple pour la désinformation
covic par exemple et l'hésitation
vaccinale facebook a trouvé que quand on
segmente la population en communauté
donc ça ce sont des segments des
cohortes sensibles
sécurité des données
4% des communautés recevait 80% des
messages d'information qu'ovide donc
certaines personnes recevaient un déluge
d'informations que ce soit de la haine
que sur la désinformation
coville que ce soit qu un jeune que ce
soit quoi que ce soit et le problème
c'est que quand vous êtes hyper exposé
déjà plus vous voyez une idée plus cette
idée semble réel deuxièmement la nature
de ce qui est promu ou ceux qui arrivent
sur votre écran est très dangereuse par
exemple pour le coc vide
un poste qui génère énormément de
commentaires a plus de chances d'être
sélectionné pour être inséré dans votre
fil d'actualité mettons que votre groupe
coville il ya un quart de million de
personnes
produit 100 cent mille
fils d'information par jour si trois
fils arrive dans votre fils
d'informations il ya des informations
provac sain et qu'il ya beaucoup de
haineux qui ont dit ah non non ce sont
des conspirations et tout cela
alors ce poste
sera considéré comme ayant beaucoup
d'interaction positive et donc il sera
promu et arrivera dans votre fil
d'informations et donc si vous verrez
que oui mais quelqu'un a essayé de
d'agir à l'encontre du groupe mais
toutes ces personnes en qui j'ai
confiance disent non c'est dangereux il
faut pas croire ça qu'est ce que vous
allez croire au final et moi ça
m'inquiète vraiment parce que il y a
besoin de 3 % de la population dans les
rues pour provoquer une révolution donc
c'est dangereux pour les démocraties
alors pour la richesse des langues comme
vous l'avez évoqué sans aucun doute vous
êtes x-bow exposés à plus de toxicité en
français en france que moi aux états
unis qui parlent anglais je pense qu'il
passe beaucoup plus de temps à gérer les
classificateurs
au mieux pour la langue anglaise pour
vous donner quelques exemples
qui sont particulièrement problématiques
il y à un milliard d'arabophones dans le
monde et facebook dit aux autorités de
contrôle oui en soutien l'arabe mais en
décembre 2020 facebook a fait un audit
l'arabe et a vu que l'audit que l'arabe
était en fait six familles de langues
arabe et facebook lent soutenait qu'une
mais a dit à tout le monde oui bien sûr
en soutien l'arabe et le problème c'est
que
quand vous n'avez pas de soutien ou très
peu de soutien à l'or
est un de mes documents on parle vous
allez avoir des discours terroristes ou
contre-terroristes 75
des % des discours contre terroristes
sont classées comme étant des discours
terroristes et et voilà c'est le genre
de problèmes qu'on peut avoir et pour
contourner ce problème il faut investir
énormément et s'assurer qu'il y ait
suffisamment de contre-exemple et
j'aimerais parler d'un dernier point sur
le français qui est plus vulnérable
je sais que ayant regardé les
statistiques sur les classements
antico vide je pense qu'on a fait un
audit de quinze langues en avril 2020 le
français était un
un une des langues qui est se comporter
les moins bien avec l'arabe et le indy
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais voilà c'est
là où l'intelligence artificielle n'a
pas pu nous le dire mais je sais que on
a eu deux des performances très mauvaise
je pense que c'était un petit peu mieux
qu'elle deux mois plus tard mais voilà
c'est un exemple et ils n'ont pas besoin
de vous montrer quels sont les systèmes
de contrôle qui fonctionne si ça ne
fonctionne pas vous n'avez vous allez
avoir des problèmes
d'expression
de liberté d'expression moi je pense que
facebook doit avoir des fonctions de la
ribouldingue donc d'étiquetage j'ai
parlé à quelqu'un pendant son voyage et
il m'a dit j'ai demandé à facebook
combien d'enfants sont surexposés aux au
contenu d'automutilation et facebook a
dit on ne trace pas les contenus
d'automutilation donc on ne sait pas
si il devait publier
quel système existe et en quelle langue
parce que à l'heure actuelle je sais
pour sûr qu'il y ait une mauvaise
représentation dans les autres langues
ils ont demandé à des personnes
d'autres langues comment il gérait les
chaussées chez facebook et bien ils vont
vous dire par exemple on a 80
partenaires internationaux
qui vérifie les contenus internationaux
donc ils vont vous dire qu'ils sont
qu'ils contrôlent les différentes
langues et qui soutiennent 50 ans mais
ils ne l'ont ils ne soutiennent pas
toutes les langues en mai 2021 il
n'avait pas de classificateurs de
discours haineux sur le indy par exemple
malgré les violences ethniques en inde
donc facebook choisi quelle langue quel
système et je vous encourage à leur
demander d exemple montrez-nous ce mille
exemples avec les classements 99e 97e et
montrez nous parce que à ce moment là on
pourrait voir oui les discours contre
terroristes sont étiquetés en tant que
terroriste où cette langue là n'est pas
soutenu autant que cet autre langue est
à l'heure actuelle facebook c'est que
personne ne sait et donc il ne gère pas
ces problèmes facebook va vous dire non
on ne peut bien sûr pas vous donner ça
parce que les méchants vont découvrir
sinon et bien les méchants le savent
déjà les méchants ils sont là et ils
sont là à publier plus de contenu pour
les groupes vulnérables et seul qui ne
savent pas ce sont les gentils et ça
c'est inacceptable
est ce que votre peau sera promue par
facebook comment la établit déjà un
facebook à temps de latence pour
intervenir sur le mauvais contenu quel
qu'il soit là je suis sûr que votre
poste va pouvoir être publiés ne vous
inquiétez surtout pas
[Musique]
annick guillou
merci monsieur le président merci madame
pour fo vos propos et la force de votre
témoignage
donc très rapidement quelques questions
le risque qu'encourent les lanceurs
d'alerté est évident et les réelles
que pensez vous qu'il faille mettre en
oeuvre pour réussir à améliorer
finalement cette dénonciation la culture
de la dénonciation est quelque chose
qu'on a du mal à à à encadrer et à
développer donc c'est la première
question la deuxième question concerne
le droit à l'oubli et notamment la
protection des jeunes et des publics
vulnérables
donc qu'est ce que vous pourriez
proposer ou pour pour réussir à protéger
ces jeunes publics où ces publics
vulnérables
une question également sur la dans la
foulée des élections aux états unis il
ya eu
donald trump a été bannie des réseaux
sociaux est ce qu'il y à un cahier des
charges qui est mis en place ou qui
devrait être mis en place pour pourvoir
pour pouvoir
finalement encadrer cette suppression de
deux réseaux sociaux et puis la dernière
question très rapidement en quoi le nom
de le changement non pardon de de
facebook est il une manière de changer
le regard qu'il faut porter sur les
activités de ce réseau social je vous
remercie
aussi la dernière question sabine
merci messieurs les présidents madame
haugen
merci aussi pour la qualité de votre
intervention et pour votre action au
combien utile deux lanceuses d' alerte
très récemment une mission d'information
du sénat sur le harcèlement scolaire et
le cyber harcèlement a rendu son rapport
et unanimement constater l'inaction des
réseaux sociaux dont le groupe facebook
a lutté contre le cyber harcèlement
scolaire nous avons d'ailleurs reçu les
responsables de facebook et d'autres et
nous n'avons pas obtenu de réponse
précise
et encore moins satisfaisante ce sujet
or les réseaux sociaux par leur
puissance d'un anonymat leur viralité
leur évolution permanente démultiplie
les conséquences du harcèlement pour nos
jeunes je souhaite avoir votre vision
votre avis vos analyses confirmez vous
confirmez vous l'inaction et je dirais à
entendre vos propos l'inaction
volontaires du groupe facebook dans la
lutte contre le cyber harcèlement et en
particulier scolaire
merci
[Musique]
concernant les lanceurs d'alert je pense
que ce sera plus de plus en plus
important d'avoir des lanceurs dallaire
parce que la technologie a toujours été
plus vite que l'intervention des
démocraties pour qu'elles servent au
mieux les démocraties ces nouvelles
technologies ont davantage de complexité
et elle s'accélère
le travail
je fais vous ne pouvez pas avoir un
doctorat dans ce que je fais ou dans un
master dans ce que je fais il faut
travailler dans des entreprises pour eux
le comprend donc on va on doit avoir des
systèmes de protection pour les
entreprises privées et publiques pour
s'assurer que les personnes sont en
sécurité et je j'encourage
d'avoir
des
associations ou des institutions de
protection de lanceurs d'alert soit
privé soit public j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance parce que je
j'ai vécu avec ma mère qui est prêtre
pendant six mois l'année dernière et
quand vous avez une crise de conscience
c'est très utile de vivre avec un prêtre
donc perso maman la plupart des lanceurs
d'alert quand il lance l'alertent
généralement ils ne vont pas très bien
ils vivent avec des vérités très dur ils
se sentent impuissants au sein de
l'entreprise et ça et ça laisse à les
anéantit et donc lanceurs d'alerté il
n'y a pas besoin uniquement
de protection juridique ils doivent
également être soutenue
avec des coachs par exemple leur dire
que voilà il y a des manières sur de
lancer l' alerte
si j'étais conduite conductrice de bus
aux états unis il y aurait eu un numéro
d'appel d'urgence dans ma salle de pause
qui m'aurait dit voilà vous avez peur
pour votre sécurité vous avez vu quelque
chose appeler ce numéro mais moi comme
je travaillais dans sur des sujets qui
avaient des conséquences nationales et
je m'inquiétais à la sécurité nationale
à l'intégrité de ma société mais je
n'avais pas d'appel d'urgence pensez-y
donc c'est dangereux c'est inacceptable
dont kylie a besoin de différents
niveaux et de différents niveaux
d'action oui
je soutiens fermement ce droit à l'oubli
les jeunes
méritent de pouvoir
remettre à zéro leurs comptes je pense
qu'il y a des opportunités où on peut
apprendre des informations abstraite
le embedding par exemple où l'ia gère un
contenu gère une image
et sauvegarde une abstraction de ce
contenu et plus tard on peut former on
peut
apprendre à une intelligence
artificielle à accomplir des tâches
grâce à cela je pense que ce qui serait
utile c'est que facebook pourrait former
une intelligence artificielle sur des
contenus qui ont été effacées par des
adolescents et ça permettrait
d'identifier des contenus qui que les
jeunes pourrait regretter à l'avenir il
ya des avants des interventions qui
pourrait être mise en place
et si c'était un problème qui voulait
être identifiées par là
[Musique]